in a venue like this you are being a
performer and a showman people just like
the sing song sometimes little Richard
just didn't sing a song as the architect
of rock and roll as the innovator as the
originator he created this art form that
was born out of it was a frenetic energy
that there's a reason that when you
heard the first bit of Lucy this is his
voice it it like did did this and went
all down is true I am so tired this
morning
last night I shot shot my uh my tribute
to Little Richard for for the B et wait
you shot the tribute last night yeah
well you know I had to repost you or you
rehearsing and you posted it on
Instagram and it just like I was in my
house going eat wait like I had to
repost it it just made me that happy big
big names on this um on this B et award
show which is a historic opportunity
because the fact that it's being
simulcast on be ET and CDX yes
CES can i'ma say it one more time CBS my
home network your home network Ed's and
it's beautiful when when you see a
chocolate chocolate face and I'm so
happy to be a part of that that
diversity now have been there for 12 the
12 seasons the fact that the BT Awards
that blows my mind and now and we're all
doing it from home so you have to step
your game up it is not just about oh I'm
on stage and looking at God pyro
it's like what can you do in your house
okay let's talk about a little bit cuz I
haven't seen it yet but I want you to
scribe to how much of an honor it was
for you for them to ask you to perform
the tribute to Little Richard and I know
what this means to you to do it right so
just kind of talk about that and talk
about how you wanted to approach this
this performance well when people see it
I think they'll see and I was just
lecturing my my daughter
on being a being an entertainer being a
showman
which is a little different sometimes
than if then then if you're being an
actor in a venue like this you are being
a performer and a showman people just
like sing songs sometimes Little Richard
just didn't sing a song as the architect
of rock and roll as the innovator as the
originator he created this art form that
was born out of it was a frenetic energy
that there's a reason that when you
heard the first bit of Lucy listen his
voice it it like did did this and went
all down is true so I wanted to treat
this performance it just wasn't like Oh
Wayne's gonna sing a song Little Richard
was an innovator and lil and Little
Richard was extra yeah he was extra
before we knew the definition of oh you
extra absolute ma I wanted to put
together a show in my house that showed
oh this is this is a a tribute to him
and all that he was in his grandiosity
and his musical prowess and the Verve
and the sex and the rock that you got
from it and the fun so that's what what
what we did because you know it's it's a
little daunting you're on an award show
with all these amazing black performers
uh sure you know a little break you
break down the performers I'm right on
the ushe I'm like how do you compete for
space with Usher and I did that by just
being me and doing what what I do when I
learned by watching the greats like
little Little Richard so I hope that I
was able to even transfer just just this
much this much of fun and love into that
show
[Music]
well and this is the 20th anniversary of
the show the 40th anniversary of Beatty
so it is a big year a big night time for
you to bring the heat and everything I
along with my partner Mandy we we
co-directed and trip and produced a
segment jason her boyfriend was our DP
and shot it along with his brother it
was a family affair miley was working on
the crew craft service so that's how we
get down in the oak coated era yeah the
core for now listen okay so you've got
some big things coming up we got a lot
to celebrate number one the Little
Richard tribute for the et board and
being like a positive image of a black
father have you
I know Miley is a is is an activist you
know teenager she knows you know who she
is
but have you have you have you and Mandy
had to have tough conversations with her
in the past few weeks and and how do
they start does she ask you questions do
you go to her well what's great is we
were having these conversations before
the the tipping points yeah and
everything exploded because we had to
have talks with her as a child of mixed
race especially when your child of mixed
race and it's human nature to categorize
upon visualization so she may be half
black quartered Japanese quarter
Caucasian but if someone looks at you
they see a black girl a light-skinned
black girl they they see you as black
what does that mean for you moving
through this world you feel the tide
changing that's a big question because
do I feel the tide changing in a global
sense all of a sudden the world goes you
know we've been doing things wrong no
because humans we value especially
Americans we value our individuality
and this is what made this country great
so even if I'm gonna speak truth to you
about how you affect me there with our
people that it'll bounce off of because
they're so rooted in their own intrinsic
beliefs but I do believe there was a
tipping point in the black community of
no not gonna take it anymore I even feel
a personal tipping point there were
things that I write about in my book and
my Broadway show where I've been silent
about a lot of things I've let a lot of
things past because the narrative that's
been fed to me is I'm lucky to be in the
room yeah I'm lucky to be one of the
people I know that we share that because
we talked you talked about it so if
you're lucky to be there do do do what
you got to do well I'm a 48 year old man
right now and I'm sick of it
so I don't just shush anymore and I stop
that a few years ago I'm gonna speak
about what I've got to speak about and I
believe that's happening to a lot of us
and that's that that's why we are big
videoing Karan's and Kevin town and if
this man says something to me I'm not
just gonna go Lord it's okay I began by
the way no no I've done it too long
[Music]